we inch closer to two years since cobit
19 first came into our lives researchers
are looking at the impact on babies born
during this time studies show they may
suffer from developmental issues and as
victoria saha explains it's not because
of the virus itself but the environment
it has created
baby mia is just about four months old
if you giggle chances are she will
giggle right back but that wasn't always
the case her grandmas would come over
and she would kind of see them but she
would still be weary mom mary gray says
that when she first brought mia home she
made everyone wear masks but then she
noticed that mia wasn't responding well
to them then the masks came off and she
recognized everyone in her family i
thought wow that's so
powerful new studies from jama
pediatrics says six-month-old babies
born during the pandemic had lower skill
developments than pre-pandemic babies
it's certainly going to be different
than previous generations it's something
parents should monitor according to dr
timothy yeater with nevada mental health
they can learn about their environment
based on what their caregivers are
showing them on their faces and so when
you limit that information then they're
going to have a little bit more limited
development as for randina she's giving
mia a lot of face time but still worries
about her upbringing during the pandemic
my biggest fear is she won't know
emotion and she won't be able to
like celebrate her birthday at school
victoria saha live local now